when I came to the trial I knew that the
trial was going to be conducted into
facto secrecy or secrecy in fact and I
decided that I wanted to know what was
going on this was the largest criminal
investigation ever into a publisher and
its source and it seemed like there was
no in-depth coverage alyssa brian is a
crowdfunded independent journalist who
has been covering the bradley manning
trial since january two thousand eleven
and she's an exceptional person because
she was the unofficial stenographer when
the trial started the website of x over
n calm has now grown to a great resource
for anyone interested in the brand new
man in case it contains infographics
document exhibit lists and is a
must-visit for anyone interested in the
bradley manning trial one of the more
important aspects of this trial that has
had gotten absolutely zip coverage is
the state department's number one role
in this case they have been in a sense a
puppet master of the military
prosecutors blocking discovery you know
the Department of State has been a
ongoing partner with the FBI and the
Department of Defense and investigating
Manning and WikiLeaks last week when
there were five journalists in the press
pool one of them was a wired journalists
department of state witnesses entered
stipulations of expected testimony about
the hundred and seventeen cables that
Manning is charged with under the
Computer Fraud and Abuse Act charge that
has an espionage clause in it and we
have yet to have any serious analysis or
coverage of these cables and how they
relate to aiding enemy how they relate
to wanted publication an unprecedented
charge in the manning trial it's never
been used in a military court-martial
it's not tied to any existing federal
violation or punitive article under the
Uniform Code of Military Justice not
tied no analysis as how they relate to
the stealing US government property or
the espionage or the the 1030 Computer
Fraud and Abuse Act any type of the area
here 13 members even publish nailed it
not
Iraq Afghanistan or targets that needs
to be neutralized by the people who were
struggling to live in a pressure cooker
environment of what we call a special
program after the news I was encouraged
by response- and general public who
observed the air like a TV as I hope
others because this trouble it doesn't
mean Viper they saw when I've spoken to
subject matter experts in military law
and also just simply you know espionage
crimes or you know constitutional
lawyers for example they all say to me
that if he gets 20 years he's lucky and
currently with his plea to 10 lesser
included offenses he's exposed to 20
years the government is going moving
forward with a case of life plus 149
that's their that's their grand case I
think that I'm not optimistic it's often
been said that you know Snowden's a
desire for asylum is a result of just
simply watching how Manning was treated
you know 1101 days of pretrial
confinement before coming to trial yet
the court rules that his speedy trial
rights haven't been violated nine months
of very strange conditions at Quantico
and only a week of that was considered
to be unlawful giving him a hundred and
twelve sentencing days credit when he's
facing a sentence of life plus 149 years
so there's that aspect but I think also
the way the US government has asserted
the 641 charges of stealing US
government property I mean that's that's
a charge against manning he has five
specifications of that and I I think
that clearly it's certainly in line with
the Obama administration's Inquisition
of whistleblowers the case is important
because it will establish a precedent
for military leaks which I think we're
going to be seeing more of as in the
future the as it becomes easier and
easier for people from privates onwards
to leaking information the last time a
member of the military was found guilty
of aiding the enemy by leaking
information to the press was in 1863
when private Henry van de water was
found guilty of leaking information
to a newspaper based in Richmond
Virginia for that crime of aiding the
enemy private VandeWater was sentenced
to three months higher labor Bradley
Manning if he is found guilty of aiding
the enemy could spend the rest of his
life in prison